[Evans] What do we need to do to make lookup faster?
Let's think about why it was so slow.
The reason it was so slow is that we were doing this for loop.
We were going through all the elements in order
and we were checking if they match the keyword.
And we had to do this going through the entire index.
For a keyword that's not in the index, to determine that it's not there
we had to go through the whole index.
This is not the way we use indexes in real life.
If you're looking for a word in the index of a book,
you don't have to look through every single entry to see if that word exists.
You can jump around.
And the reason you can jump around is because the entries in the index are sorted.
They're sorted in alphabetical order, so you know where that entry would belong.
You just need to find the right place and see if it's there.
So we could do that with our index.
Instead of having our index kept in arbitrary order,
if we kept our index in a sorted order, then we could find the place where that entry belongs
and look for it.
Sorting is a very interesting problem.
It's something we're not actually going to talk about more in this class.
We're going to do a different way of doing that.
What we're going to do is find a way to find where the entry should be
that doesn't require actually keeping all the entries sorted.
What we want is something that will allow us, given a keyword,
we're going to have some function that tells us where it belongs.
We're going to call that a hash function.
That tells us where in the entry to look.
And so instead of having to look through the whole index,
the hash function will tell us where that entry belongs.
So what we need for this is some function that's going to take a keyword,
map it to a number, and that number is the position in the index where that entry belongs.
We could do this lots of different ways.
One simple thing would be to think we know the alphabet;
this is more like the way an index for a book would work,
and for each entry in the index we'll have--
based on the first letter we'll put all the entries that start with that first letter in the same place.
So if we're looking for a keyword that starts with U,
that word for our hash would tell us to look in the place
where all the words that start with U are,
and then we'd only have to look through the words that start with U.
So this would allow us to do a lookup
much more quickly than looking through the whole index.
This isn't quite the best way to do things.
If we made our places based on the letter, then we have a problem
if we have 2 words with the same first letter.
Certainly we expect to have more than 1 word that starts with the same letter.
So instead of having just an element here for each position,
we're going to have a list of elements that would be all the words that start with U.
So when we look up the word Udacity, we would look in the entry for U,
and if the word that's there doesn't match, then we know Udacity isn't in the index.
There are lots of problems with this.
The first problem is there might be more than 1 word that starts with U,
so we can't just have 1 entry here.
What we need to have is a list of entries.
We often call this a bucket.
We need a bucket of all the entries that start with U that would be in this position.
So instead of having just 1 entry like the old structure of our index,
now we're going to have a list of entries, and each element of the index will now be a bucket,
which is a list of entries that are in the right position.
This is going to be our bucket of all the entries that start with U,
and that would have all the different entries that start with the letter U in that bucket.
This is getting better.
Now for each lookup, instead of having to look through all of the words in the index,
we just need to find the position that starts with the right letter
that's got a bucket of all the words that start with that letter,
and then we just need to look through that bucket.
This works okay, but this doesn't really scale very well.
At best, if we have 10 million words,
now instead of having 10 million entries to go through,
we need to go through 10 million divided by, say, 26 if we have 26 letters.
It's not making things much faster.
It's making things maybe at best 26 times letter.
That assumes that all of the buckets are the same size.
Certainly if we make the buckets based on the first letter,
that's not going to be the same size.
If the words are typical English words,
we're going to have many more words that start with S and T than start with U.
So we want to fix those 2 problems.
We want to be able to have more buckets,
so we're not going to just use the first letter,
we're going to use some function on the whole word that tells us where it belongs,
and we're going to try to make that function distribute the words fairly well.
The structure that I've described is what's called a hash table.
This is a very useful data structure.
It's so useful that it's built in to Python.
There's a Python type called a dictionary which provides this functionality.
At the end of today's unit I'll explain how the Python dictionary works and how to use it,
and we'll modify the search engine code to use dictionary
instead of the lookup table that we built.
But before we do that, we're going to implement it ourselves.
We're going to make sure that we understand how the hash table works
by writing all the code to do it ourselves,
and then we'll switch to using the built-in Python type.